AS THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID,
STATE AND LOCAL LEADERS DECIDE
WHEN TO OPEN UP AND THE
PROBLEM IS A DISK DISASTROUS
GROUPTHINK HAS EMERGED AROUND
THE EXTREME VERSION OF DOCTOR
POUCHES PLAN.
>> I THINK WIDESPREAD TESTING
AND CONTACT TRACING WILL BE
ESSENTIAL TO FINDING OUT
EXACTLY WHERE WE ARE IN THIS
FIGHT AGAINST THIS DEADLY
VIRUS.
>> THE VARIABLES WILL INCLUDE
THE CAPACITY OF THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM TO IDENTIFY, ISOLATE
AND TREAT THOSE INFECTED SO
THEY CAN SLOW THE SPREAD.
>> WE CAN’T OPEN THE COUNTRY
BACK UP UNTIL WE CAN DO
TESTING ON A MASSIVE SCALE.
WHY ARE WE EVEN CLOSE.
>> IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE
HEALTHCARE EXPERTS BELIEVE, TO
REOPEN THE COUNTRY SHORT OF A
VACCINE, WHICH IS A YEAR OR SO
AWAY, UNLESS THERE IS
WIDESPREAD TESTING.
>> JUST IN THE LAST FEW DAYS
THE ESTABLISHMENT PUT UP A NEW
ROADBLOCK TO REOPEN, TRIPLING
THE NUMBER OF TEST IDENTIFIED
THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
INFECTED AND ISOLATE THEM FROM
PEOPLE WHO ARE HEALTHY.
THIS IS ESTABLISHMENT
GROUPTHINK.
IT’S MISINFORMATION.
IT IGNORES THE LATEST DATA.
NO SURPRISE BIG BUSINESS HAS
BOUGHT INTO IT TOO.
THEY TOLD AMAZON SHAREHOLDERS
THIS WEEK THAT THOSE WHO TEST
POSITIVE COULD BE QUARANTINED
AND EVERYONE WHO TEST NEGATIVE
COULD REENTER THE ECONOMY WITH
CONFIDENCE.
WHAT AN IDIOTIC STATEMENT.
WE HAVE ENOUGH PROBLEMS
WITHOUT THROWING OUT
UNSCIENTIFIC MUMBO-JUMBO.
SOME STATES LOCAL LEADERS ARE
TALKING, GAVIN NEWSOM SAID
CALIFORNIA WILL NEED TO DO
WIDESPREAD CONTACT TRACING
BEFORE RELAXING THEIR
STAY-AT-HOME ORDER.
THESE PEOPLE AND THEIR PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS TALK TO
DOCTOR FAUCI’S.
I’D LIKE TO TALK TO HIM.
HIS ADVICES LARGELY
CONTROVERSIAL.
WE’VE BEEN ASKING FOR A WHILE
BUT UNFORTUNATELY HE WON’T
TALK TO US.
TONIGHT I’M GOING TO ASK THE
QUESTIONS ANYWAY AND SEE IF WE
GET A REPLY.
ONE, DOCTOR OUCHI YOU KEEP
TELLING US YOU ARE LED BY THE
SCIENCE AND THE DATA.
WHY IS YOUR DATA SO WRONG FOR
SO LONG.
WHY DIDN’T YOU COMMISSION
SURVEY TESTING LIKE THE
SANFORD TEAM JUST CARRIED OUT
TO GET AN ACCURATE PICTURE OF
THE SPREAD AND FATALITY OF
THIS VIRUS.
WILL YOU CARRY OUT NATIONWIDE
SURVEY TESTING IMMEDIATELY?
TWO, BASED ON THIS NEW DATA DO
YOU NOW EXCEPT THAT IT’S
UNNECESSARY AND IMPRACTICAL TO
IDENTIFY, ISOLATE AND CONTACT
TRACE EVERYONE WHO HAS THIS
VIRUS.
THREE, WILL YOU TELL THE
GOVERNMENT, THE MEDIA, THE BIG
BUSINESS BOSSES THAT
WIDESPREAD VIRUS TESTING OF
INDIVIDUALS IS NOT NECESSARY
FOR REOPENING?
WILL YOU RULE OUT IMMUNITY
CERTIFICATES IMMEDIATELY.
FOR, DO YOU AGREE THAT ALL
DEATHS MATTER NOT JUST
CORONAVIRUS DEATHS.
WILL YOU COMMIT TO A STUDY OF
THE LONG-TERM PUBLIC HEALTH
COST OF THE SHUTDOWN TO HELP
INFORM ANY FUTURE PANDEMIC
RESPONSE LIKE SUICIDE, RISE IN